[music]
>> Yeah. So, like like Phil said, I work at
Pomerium and he's not the first person
to have trouble pronouncing it. So, I
actually convinced the marketing team to
uh create Pomeranian stickers. So, if
anybody wants Pomeranian stickers, I
have a bunch with me.
Um bit about me, uh
I'm a dev advocate over at Pomerium as
Phil said. Um from Canada, uh hailing
from Montreal. So, uh
if anybody likes poutine and bagels,
feel free to chat with me after.
Uh also a GitHub star, Microsoft MVP,
and AWS community builder. And these you
can pretty much find me everywhere uh at
Nikki T online.
Um I was pretty happy to see this that
there's a a pretty sizable instance on
prem of Open Claw. So, I was pretty
happy with that. And it looks like
that's the operator there.
Cool. So,
uh
I don't know, I came up with a funny
title, I guess, but Clawzette. Um we're
going to talk about a feature I
contributed to the Open Claw project
back in February.
And it's about hardening access to the
control plane. So, uh I'm assuming
everybody here is running an Open Claw
or Open Claw curious. Um
is anybody running uh a mode called
trusted proxy auth mode? You you might
not be, but uh okay. You might be on the
Who's on the token auth?
Okay.
Um anyways, so
at Pomerium where I work, um you know,
I'm always just trying to secure things.
That's just part of what I do.
And I was able to secure Open Claw, but
it meant I still had to add a token uh
for the web socket connection. I had to
always pair my device and stuff.
And you don't really need that with uh a
trusted proxy. Like specifically the one
that I work on, which is Open Core, it's
called an identity-aware proxy. So, if
anybody's ever used GCP, uh there's a
IAP in there. It's called an
identity-aware proxy, something that
came out of Google. Uh essentially,
you've got an identity provider, a
policy engine, and a reverse proxy. So,
those
uh it's not the lethal trifecta in the
sense that you usually hear, but uh it's
a pretty solid security approach for
securing internal apps.
So, I was like, of course, I I I kind of
got annoyed that I had to add this token
still and do the pairing every time.
Uh I understood why they were there, but
uh I just proposed this issue and then
uh at least one other person who uses
Caddy uh chimed in and said, "Hey,
that's uh sounds like a good idea."
And then Peter uh Stipe was like, "Yeah,
let's let's work on this." And he laid
out like the criteria that he wanted to
have for this feature.
So, I went ahead and worked on it. And
yeah, again, prior to trusted proxy auth
mode,
even if you were secured by a proxy, you
still had to paste in that auth token in
the UI for the web socket connection.
And also it sticks it in the query
string, which uh obviously like this is
really more for just only local mode
really. Um and still having to pair the
device. Like uh I don't know if people
get annoyed by pairing the device, but
uh I you know, I I'd just be on a my
phone after I just set it up. And then I
was like, "Uh I got to go to the other
thing to set it up." So, um basically,
you still had to do those things even if
it was secured with uh a proxy.
So, got merged in and uh I felt pretty
good about it. And uh it was
nice to get some praise from Peter. It
was uh my first contribution to the
project. So,
it's very cool. So, what does it look
like exactly like in the config? Uh I'm
just going to show like a kind of narrow
part of the config here, but you have
your gateway. And essentially, you no
longer need the token like I mentioned.
Uh the mode is obviously different, so
it's called trusted proxy now. And then
there's some new properties you have to
add. So, there's trusted proxies. And
this is essentially the proxy that is
gating access to the control plane, the
uh the gateway.
Um it's the IP addresses. It could be
one or more.
And aside from that, you have to have a
trusted proxy section. So, you'll have a
user header, which is in in my case uh
it's a jot,
uh JWT. Um and then there's like a
required header section. There's some
optional ones, too. It depends what you
want to do. There's like allowed users.
And in my case, I don't need the allowed
users because the way uh identity-aware
proxy works is the policies dictate
that. Um but essentially, that's
kind of the big change there. And you
can do this through the onboarding or if
you just go back in and
uh configure things through the TUI.
And yeah, so that just meant no more
token for web socket connections and no
longer needed to pair devices. So, not
only are you
uh getting uh better security posture
potentially,
uh
to me it's like a UX win as well cuz I
really found doing these two things
annoying.
Um
Cool. Uh I also just want to give a
shout-out to a couple contributors after
I contributed this.
Um
there was a bug and Anthony reported it
and then uh Sid fixed it. And
uh
it was definitely something I missed
because I basically was testing this on
my local environment and I already had
something paired. So, I didn't run into
the issue that uh Anthony had mentioned.
So, uh
luckily uh it was a small fix and uh Sid
got that sorted out. But just uh
you know, when you miss stuff, uh people
in the community step up. So,
OSS for the win.
The other thing I want to mention is not
so much about this feature, but like
when I opened this issue, uh
the number of the issue was 1560.
And I had a a PR initially that was like
in the 1700s.
And I went on vacation and I said, "Oh,
I'll get back to it when I'm back."
And the original PR was closed cuz it
was stale. And like literally after 2
weeks, it went from like 1500 to like
almost 16,000. So, uh
basically, that's just a testament to
how popular the project got. But also
meant I had to rebase quite a bit before
it got merged. So, anyways, I don't know
if anybody else that contributes
[clears throat] to the project, but
there's so many things going on all the
time. So, there's a lot of uh rebasing
to keep your thing up to date.
Cool.
So, uh
let's talk about my own Open Claw. So,
this is my claw.
And he's sitting on my desk in Montreal
right now. There's some snow still.
Um I use it in Discord. I don't know
where people use their Open Claw. I had
it on Telegram initially, but they don't
actually uh
uh their their uh channels aren't
encrypted. So, like all the stuff's in
clear. So, I work at a security company
and my CEO is like, "Yeah, don't use
that." So, anyways, uh I'm mainly on
Discord. I find it use uh handy that
way. I have WhatsApp, too, but I tend to
use the Discord more.
Um
Some things I want to mention, too, is
when I made the contribution, I actually
used Open Claw to make the contribution,
which was kind of fun.
Um but it also uh I made the mistake of
I used the GitHub CLI and I gave it full
access. So, it put up a PR right away
even before I was like done reviewing
things. Uh so, I had a little like,
"Ah."
But uh put it back in a draft mode. Um
but aside from that,
um
after the uh token uh trusted proxy mode
got merged, I just started working on
something. It started getting fun to
just build stuff on my phone. So, I
built out something called Claw Space.
And you know, doesn't doesn't mean you
need to use it. It's just, you know,
it's the age of personal software. I
just had a lot of fun building it. I
find it useful.
And I thought it was just cool that I
could build this out on my phone on
Discord.
Um but for me, I find it useful because
I don't need to SSH in to see workspace
files that I want to actually read or
like edit. Uh so, uh that's just a
little side project I started building.
And you can edit files and stuff, too.
Cool.
So, we're going to do a demo here. This
is going to be uh live coding. So, YOLO.
Okay.
So,
uh there's a MCP track tomorrow. Uh I've
been doing a lot of work in MCPs. So,
what we're going to do is we are going
to build out an MCP, uh not a
full-fledged version of something.
But if you've seen the uh
AI engineer website, they have like a
LMs text on the right. And there's a MCP
server and there's a few other things.
So, I'm going to go ahead and just add
this here.
And I'm going to go create an app.
I'll explain some things here in a
second.
Okay.
And OAuth. Okay.
So, this is going to go create an
application in ChatGPT.
Uh but basically, this is uh an MCP
server that just has UI as well. They'll
they'll be talking about this tomorrow.
But uh
I have a template that I use for this.
So, it's not like I'm building this from
scratch. But we're just going to
register the MCP here. and then I'm just
going to start building with open claw.
And the thing with a gentic is you never
know when it's done. It's just finishing
up a wath here.
Okay, cool. It's connected and
we can see here it's got two tools. It's
got a echo tool and it's got a search
speakers tool.
So if we come here
if nobody's ever used MCP apps
basically in chat GPT do this for your
app and I'm going to say like echo
hello.
And essentially it's going to do the
tool call but because there is UI
associated to it, you're going to get
some UI in here.
And this is just using the standard MCP
stuff that's in the spec now. Um so you
can do stuff like change that, make it
big and stuff. But what I want to show
is like when I'm building this with open
claw, I can do stuff like this. I can
say like
uh ba ba ba
change
echo message
to
AIEU
in the echo widget.
Now it's going to take a second but um
this is all web tech under the hood so I
don't know if anybody's web devs here
but essentially it's using V and react
so there's react refresh and V hot
module reloading. McClaw is on the case
here and you can see I'm in chat GPT I'm
editing live from my workspace the MCP
and and to explain how this is working,
uh we have the trusted proxy off mode.
Uh I happen to be using pomerium in this
case so I'm using it as well to secure
other things in the workspace so I have
a public URL that I've gated for the MCP
and that's how I'm able to use it in
chat GPT.
And I can go ahead and just keep working
on it in here and I don't know how other
people work or build with uh
open claw but this is kind of how I've
been doing it. I find it works really
well for web dev stuff.
So I'm going to go say update the search
speaker so let's just do this in new
chat.
And I'll say at AIE again
search speakers.
And it's going to give uh a very minimal
UI here cuz there's not much into it. Uh
so I'm going to just tell McClaw to get
on the case here.
And basically if you go to that top
right corner of the AIE uh website,
there's uh speaker.json and this is like
all the speakers from the conf
and we're going to use that as like the
source of users and then I'm asking it
to kind of give the same UI as what you
kind of saw in the echo widget. Uh it's
going to take a minute here probably cuz
uh McClaw is covered in snow probably in
Montreal but uh
cool. And so basically once this gets
done
uh we'll be able to filter users and
just kind of you know see who's talking
um
at the conference and I'm just going to
take a sip of water while McClaw is
chugging along there.
Again, you never know when a gentic
finishes.
Okay, it's deterministic and it's
deterministically
an indeterminate.
So it should be done in a second and
then what you're going to see is you're
going to see this updated and again just
to reiterate the flow
I'm I'm working in workspace files in my
open claw. I'm speaking to it or typing
to it in discord.
Uh this is a publicly available site uh
and I'm able to build it as I'm in my
open claw and
I like that workflow. I really don't
know how other people work. I mean
obviously I use other tools like Claude
and and Codex too. Uh but you can see
here um
McClaw was able to get the job done and
then I can start filtering so we could
look for drilling down here then we can
find a speaker and then we can get a bit
more information
and then like I could say let's add
another feature here so let's get McClaw
on the case again.
So we're going to add a more button here
and there's this send message function
that you can use in MCP apps and this is
actually going to
uh when you click the but the more
button that it's going to generate, this
will actually make a call to the LLM to
and you're going to get a response back.
Uh so we'll give this a second.
Uh ba da ba da ba.
Cool. So I added this more button in
uh again like I've been doing web dev
for a while and I I always still find it
magical when things just automatically
update but I'm going to go ahead and
click on here
and you're going to see here that it's
thinking now so it actually made a call
uh
added another uh prompt to chat GPT here
and it's going to kind of summarize why
it thinks you should check out
Alessandro's talk and a bit more about
it. Now
I just really find this workflow really
cool. It's only possible if you use some
kind of proxy to do this. Uh you can do
this with others like uh caddy with
oauth. You could do it with uh well
engine X is kind of deprecated at this
point. We're not deprecated but uh at
least in Kubernetes land the ingress
controller is. Um but it's just a really
nice way to gate stuff that is local but
you can still expose it in a secure way.
Um and it's also just fun built. Like I
don't know about anybody else but I've
been really enjoying building stuff just
chatting.
Uh I remember a couple years ago uh
replit um who's who's a AI company
that's you know making it really easy to
build stuff. I was like why would I ever
want to build on my phone and uh
I kind of got uh phone killed now I
guess so. Um just fun you know just
having fun. I think that's part of the
thing with open claw. Also just like use
it however you want to. Like I I find
that claw space I created super helpful.
Uh you know build your own tools and
stuff. Um definitely take security into
consideration. Uh you know there's a
bunch of people that have obviously
you know exposed things and they didn't
mean to. Like you know some people have
deleted all their emails etc. Um but I
don't know. I I find the trusted proxy
off mode super useful and at least one
other person does in the in the in that
issue.
Um I encourage you to check it out. Uh
just have fun building stuff and
that's uh pretty much it. My name is
Nick Taylor and that's how I build with
open claw.
>> [applause]
[music]